it's competitive sports yes acknowledged by god
is what is it acknowledged by god acknowledged
yes okay competitive sports they are not of
god they're contrary to the spirit of christ
christ's spirit is i lose so you can win that's
calvary i lose for your sakes he became poor
that ye through his poverty might become rich
competitive sport says i will do everything i can
to stop you from scoring one goal i will slam you
to the boards in ice hockey i will break your legs
in football i will look undercut you in basketball
i will whatever competitive sports are not of god
i'm upsetting those of you who worship
arsenal manchester united competitive
sports are not of god this is the houston astros
or whatever they are not of god are you with me
recreation is of god difference i remember
many years ago i was in the house of a
friend of mine and he had a table tennis in the
basement so he and i were just hitting the ball
he said let's play a game i said why
come on let's play why let's hit the ball come on
let's play a game so we'll play i beat him 21 5.
that was the end of his desire to play a game
he wanted someone to win or lose this is not
the spirit of god you see it on pick up games on
the playgrounds someone fouled and i didn't foul
you foul they look like a fowl you fouled
it no not me they put their hands up lying
lying competitive sports are not of god
you